LYNNE COX: Hi.
Good afternoon.
I'm Lynne Cox and I'm
really happy to be
here with you at Google.
As a background for the book
that I've written and you're
reading or finding out about,
I'm an open water swimmer.
I started my career when I was
14 years old by swimming
across the Catalina Channel.
When I was 15 years old, I
swam across the English
Channel and broke all records
for men and women.
My time was broken by a man
named David Hart from
Massachusetts.
So the following year, I went
back and broke his time and
swam three miles further
than the first time.
So the second time I did
it, I swam 33 miles.
There are many people who swim
across the English Channel and
they go back again and again.
And sometimes, there are
swimmers that swim 25, or 30,
or 50 times even.
And I decided that I didn't
want to continue to do the
same thing over and
over again.
So I set the goal of swimming
across Cook Straits in a
straight line between
the North and South
Island of New Zealand.
The distance is 10 miles.
And I figured that I would swim
this crossing in five
hours and try to be the first
woman to do that swim.
Well instead of reaching this
point after five hours, I
realized from my crew that we'd
been going backwards for
five hours and that was
kind of discouraging.
But the cool thing is that there
was a radio announcer on
board the boat who was giving
up-to-date weather information
and also he was telling
the people throughout
Christchurch, New Zealand and
Wellington about the swim.
And so people throughout the
country started calling in to
the boat and wishing me well.
And then Air New Zealand got
involved and started relaying
weather information to us.
And I kept swimming seven hours
into the swim, eight
hours into the swim.
And there was a cross-channel
ferry that came out and raised
the American flag.
And all the people on board
the boat came out
and cheered me on.
And I realized that
guilt was a really
big motivating factor.
And I kept swimming for more
hours and had the support of
the people from all over New
Zealand by the end the swim.
And when the swim was completed
after 12 hours and 2
and 1/2 minutes, we went back
by boat to the North Island
and the boat almost sank a
couple times because the water
was so rough.
Finally, the next day, as
celebration for the swim,
church bells were rung
throughout the country.
And I realized then that a swim
that I did could be more
than just an athletic event.
That it could be something
that might
bring people together.
So in 1976, I started trying
to get permission to swim
across the Bering Strait.
And it took 11 years.
I wrote to Brezhnev, Chernenko,
Andropov.
And finally Gorbachev gave
approval for this swim
basically a day before or a
couple days before this swim.
But they had moved ships from
the South China Sea into the
Bering Strait.
And they spent pretty much a
million dollars on the event
and opened the border for the
first time in 48 years.
And when Reagan and Gorbachev
were signing the peace treaty,
the INF missile treaty,
Gorbachev stood up and toasted
the swim and said it showed how
close to each other the
two countries are.
In a straight line, it's only
2.7 miles from Little Diomede
in the United States to Big
Diomede in the Soviet Union.
And it took me two hours
and six minutes.
And I swam in 42 degree water,
that dropped to 38 degree, in
a swimsuit, cap, and goggles.
And so when Gorbachev made the
toast, President Reagan
toasted him back.
And then they signed the INF
missile treaty and basically
helped to open the border and
diminish tensions between the
two countries.
After that, I went on to do
other really challenging swims
and in progressively colder
and colder waters.
There was a group of scientists
at UC Santa Barbara
who were studying me when I was
there at college, trying
to figure out how I acclimated
to the cold water.
And then there was a professor
and a medical doctor named Dr.
Liam Keating, who was the
world's expert on hypothermia,
who started researching me and
asking me if I'd come to
London to be part of their
research study.
So from these scientists, I was
able to really learn how
to push further, and acclimate
to the cold, and go into
colder and colder waters.
In 2002, I swam 1.22 miles in 32
degrees from "Orlova," the
ship, to the shores
of Antarctica.
And at the end of the swim,
there were flocks of penguins
that jumped into the water and
swam out to meet us and then
went into shore with us.
And you could see them just
dolphining through the water.
And then you can see them in
the water because the water
was so clear, it was like
looking through the sky.
But it was so cold, that it felt
like it was like swimming
through slush.
I swam for 25 minutes in
32 degree water and
succeeded on that swim.
And then I've written now--
this actually is
my fifth book.
My first book was called
"Swimming to Antarctica." And
it was about a lot of those
swims and a lot more, about
the adventures, about the
people, about what you learn
on these different journeys.
And then I went on to write a
book called "Grayson." And
that was about a baby gray whale
that got lost off the
coast of Seal Beach while I
was training to swim the
Catalina Channel the
second time.
And that book was a best seller,
as was "Swimming to
Antarctica." And "Grayson"
is now
translated into 20 languages.
My third book was "South with
the Sun." And it's about polar
exploration and Amundsen, who
was the first man to reach the
South Pole.
And I wrote about him because
I was so inspired by him.
But I think that as athletes
and as people who read and
people who have traveled, we're
adventures and we're
exploring our limits and
we're exploring the
possibilities of life.
And so I really felt it was
so important to be able to
incorporate Amundsen's journey
with who mentored him, and who
he mentored, and then to follow
the course of his
journey and do certain
swims along the way.
So I swam off of Greenland.
The water temperature there was
28.8 and dropped to 26.6,
in a swimsuit, cap,
and goggles.
I just swam a quarter
of mile for five
minutes and 10 seconds.
But that was as far as
I'd ever gone before.
And the idea was that I'd go
back home to train for another
month and then went back to
swim in Baffin Island.
And it was really wild to go
there because when you land
there by plane--
I had a crew member with me.
We landed in July and we had to
wait seven days for the ice
to break for me to be
able to do the swim.
So we swam between the broken
ice, and the water was
primarily 28.8 degrees, and I
swam a mile in swimsuit, cap,
and goggles.
Part of this was still for the
research and to look at how
you could acclimate to the cold,
but also survival and
better ways of rewarming
after cold exposure.
I did a number of other
swims after that.
And then decided that I really
needed to write a book for
open water swimming people,
people that were triathletes,
or runners, or cyclists, or
paddlers, or people who were
going into the open water.
Because I felt like through all
these years, now 40 years
of doing these different swims,
that there was a wealth
of information that had been
given to me by people who were
elite athletes, from runners,
to swimmers, to astronauts.
And so I decided that I really
needed to write this open
water swimming manual to be able
to give people access to
that information.
But in writing the book, I
also realized that it was
really important to continue
to go out and ask experts
stuff I didn't know, that
would make the book more
interesting.
And what I also wanted to do
is incorporate anecdotes so
that the story would be really
readable and that you would
get lots of information, but you
enjoy it as you read it.
Recently, I think a couple weeks
ago, Michael Bamberger,
who's a senior editor for
"Sports Illustrated" did a
review on the book and basically
said it was a great
summer read, in addition to
being a great book that is
like Jim Fixx's book, who wrote
about "The Complete Book
of Running."
So he sort of sees this
whole era now as the
next running era.
The slimming has taken over in
terms of people wanting to go
into the open water and swim.
People who are older athletes,
who are sort of beaten up by
their sport and now want to try
something new or people
who have done their sport for
a long time and just really
want the challenge of swimming
in the open water.
One of the things that I was
really, really, really lucky
about doing was the US Navy
SEALs offered to let me come
to Coronado Island in San Diego
area to learn from them
and to find out how they were
able to risk manage and make
the swim safer for the SEAL
trainees and for the more
elite SEAL officers, who train
there to go off on missions
into far off places.
And so they allowed me to spend
off and on two years
learning from them and
asking questions.
And I was able to capture a lot
of their anecdotes and put
them in the book as
a way to say--
for instance, there was one
officer who told me about his
experience of going into
hypothermia, where his
temperature dropped severely and
he was extremely cold and
he was in a bad state.
And being able to tell that
story, I was able to also
explain what hypothermia is,
what you look like, or
somebody looks like when they go
into hypothermia, and what
to do if somebody is in
a hypothermic state.
And I was able to draw on
the expertise of Gordon
Giesbrecht, who is the expert
up in Manitoba, Canada, who
can tell you all about the
physiology behind hypothermia.
In addition, I was able to then
talk about what to do to
prevent hypothermia and how to
condition for colder waters so
that you prepare in advance so
you don't experience this.
The other thing that I was
trying to do is explain that
when you're in the open water,
it's this great adventure
where you get to see things you
would never see on land.
A good friend of mine, her
name is Cindy Hunter, and
she's a marine biologist at
the University of Hawaii.
And so she, for instance, gave
me her take on what it is like
for her to look at coral reefs
and their significance.
And what happens if, for
instance, you knock off an
inch piece of that coral.
And if you do, and if you get
stung by the coral, then
there's a whole chapter in there
of what to do if you get
stung by jellyfish or sting
rays or coral, and how to
enjoy the water a lot more, and
how to swim more safely.
And really the reason for the
book was to help people have
fun in the water and to connect
with other people who
are really out there
and enjoying it.
So instead of just talking on
and on, I just thought maybe I
would open this up to see if you
might have some questions
about the book, or about open
water swimming, or about
anything that may pertain
to the subject?
We'll see.
AUDIENCE: How do you prepare
to go into such cold water?
LYNNE COX: How do I prepare to
go into such cold water?
Actually, I started preparing
for cold water when I
was 14 years old.
That was the first time I swam
across Catalina Channel.
The water temperature there
was about 70 degrees.
And my dad suggested that what
we do to prepare for it--
there were three other
14-year-olds and one other
12-year-old that were planning
to do the swim.
And so what we did is we only
swam in the ocean so that our
bodies would start to acclimate
to the colder water
temperature.
The pool temperature
was 76 degrees.
And we found that if we swam
in the pool, we'd overheat.
We'd start sweating and
turn bright red.
So by swimming only in the
ocean, that started our
acclimatization process.
But we also did things
like during--
it was summer and fall.
So I only trained with this
group of swimmers
for about six weeks.
They had been training
for a year.
But I had been training with
Don Gambril, who was the US
Olympic coach.
So I was sort of trying to
acclimate very quickly.
And my dad suggested that I
sleep with the windows open at
night, and that I only sleep
with a sheet, and don't wear
heavy pajamas, and wear sandals,
and try to get my
body used to a colder
temperature.
So that's what I did for the
Catalina Channel swim.
The English Channel swim was
significantly colder.
It was 56 degrees.
And so all winter long, I'd
leave the windows open.
I'd wear very light
clothes in winter.
In Southern California, the air
temperature gets down to
48 degrees.
So that helped a lot.
But I basically, through
the years, did
colder and longer swims.
So the Bering Strait swim was
in 38 degree water for two
hours and six minutes.
The swim in the Antarctic
was just 25
minutes and 32 degrees.
I really had a hard time
training for that because the
coldest water I could get into
was in Ushuaia, Argentina, at
the very tip of Argentina, and
the water temperature there
was 42 degrees.
So what I did is I tried to work
out in a way that I swam
slower to cool my body down
a little bit more.
But I also trained putting
in my face in the water.
So that would cool my body
down a little faster too.
You lose 80% of heat
through your head.
So I thought, OK, during
training I'll get a little bit
colder than I normally would.
And then when I went down to
Antarctica, when I actually
did the swim from the ship to
the shores of Antarctica, I
swam head up like a
water polo player.
Because you lose 80% of heat
through your head, you lose
the heat really,
really quickly.
So I thought if I swam head up
for the majority of the swim,
I'd be able to contain
more heat in my body.
I also did a few weird
things, but whatever.
Because you're doing things that
have never been done and
you don't know how it's
going to work.
So you're going to just try
a variety of things.
I always look at nature to
see what's possible.
And when you look at penguins,
there like this big, like the
Gentoo penguins.
And they're like kind of rotund
or cylinder shaped.
And their body is really amply
coated with body fat and it's
really well distributed.
And then outside the layer
of body fat are feathers.
So there's this air insulation
that exists between the body
and the feathers.
And that's what really keeps
them warm is the air between
the two, and their body fat.
So I figured what I'll do before
I swim in Antarctica is
I'll grow my hair really long.
And I'll wind it up and pile it
on top of my head and put
it under my bathing cap.
And I won't squish
out the air.
And when I swim, I'll swim
head up and maybe I can
contain my body heat better.
There were other things that I
did to try to help me that
again nobody had ever
done this before.
And I don't think anyone ever
really wanted to do it anyway.
So it was a really big
stretch for me.
So I do know that one of the
side effects of hypothermia is
that you become dehydrated and
that also helps to contribute
to becoming hypodermic.
So before my swim in Antarctica,
I decided, OK, you
need to make your body
like a thermos.
Because you've got basically
your body, your body fat, and
then your skin.
And your skin will close down
the blood flow really well.
That's what it's been
trained to do.
And it'll close it down and
it'll move it from the
extremities into the core of
your body to protect your
brain and vital organs.
But I thought maybe if I can
warm up my core temperature
before I start swimming, maybe
that will help me on the swim.
So what I did is I drank four
8 ounces of really hot water
to put into the thermos before
I started the swim.
And then because of the research
I've been doing, we
wound up getting a pre-core
temperature before I swam.
My body temperature was up to
102 before I started the swim.
And then after the swim was
over, we couldn't get an
immediate core temperature,
but it was down to 97.
And within an hour, it
was back up to 102.
So my body has learned how to
get back up to my normal
temperature very quickly.
But the other thing that it
learned to do too is that
through time, through all these
years of training and
acclimating to the colder water,
the researchers found
that my body temperature learned
how to lower itself.
So that my normal temperature
wasn't 98.7, it
was more like 97.6.
So the way they explained that
acclimatization was that I was
able to lower my thermostat so
my body didn't have to work as
hard to stay warm.
And then to continue with your
question actually, I think
that the training that I've
done has been really
progressive through many,
many, many years.
And I've had basically lowered
the temperature that I've been
swimming in very gradually
and then tried to
go further in it.
The swim that I did off
Greenland in 28.8, that
dropped to 26.6, I really
couldn't train for that.
That's not a great thing.
But I had done the swim
in Antarctica.
And I really didn't think
there'd be a huge difference
between 32 degree
water and 28.
I didn't realize it
would drop to 26.
And I was really wrong.
There was a huge difference
between 32
degrees and 26 degrees.
And it made me think of a whole
bunch of things like
when you get below a certain
degree temperature water, is
the effect of the cold
exponential?
Does your body lose heat more
rapidly than if the water was
56 degrees and it
dropped to 50?
I don't know.
I know though that when you're
training for different swims,
if you swim in fresh water
that's 70 degrees and if you
swim in 70 degree salt water,
the fresh water will always
feel cooler than
the salt water.
And I don't know what that is.
And I've asked physicists
and I've asked
all sorts of people.
But there's just a
real difference.
And then I thought well maybe
here more buoyant in the salt
water so you have less of your
body exposed, so maybe you
don't feel the water temperature
as much or maybe
the salt in the water blocks
your perception of it.
And when you swim for so long,
you think about a lot of
different things.
And I think a lot of it too is
you're always looking for how
can I do this better, how can
I reach further, what can I
learn from what I've just done,
what can I learn from
people around me that have had
similar experiences, and how
can I integrate that and try
to do something more?
So that's sort of how I
acclimate to the cold.
Any more questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
LYNNE COX: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just wondering like in
terms of the whole building
awareness and social media
didn't exist back then.
And like I can't just go to my
neighborhood post office and
write Gorbachev.
Like how do you make these
connections, and how do you
raise the awareness, and get
yourself out there so that
people actually know this is
what I'm doing, come support
me, and get the support from I
guess the whole countries from
the leadership standpoint?
LYNNE COX: What a
great question.
I mean it was incredible.
I didn't have Google back
then in 1987 to be
able to get the support.
Or I didn't know anything about
it to do these swims.
And so I wound up just starting
off with what I knew.
And what I knew was first to
start off by contacting the
local congressman, who actually
thought that the swim
across the Bering Strait for
instance might be possible.
So he wound up writing a letter
to the Soviet Embassy.
And then I realized that it was
time to contact the State
Department.
But I didn't know
who to contact.
So I started writing letters
to George Shultz.
And I'm talking about the Bering
Strait swim because
that was 11 years of trying to
figure out how to open the
border between the US and
the Soviet Union.
And the other part of that swim
that was so difficult was
that nobody believes that the
Soviets would open the border.
That was number one.
Number two, nobody believed that
anyone could swim in a
bathing suit, cap, and goggles
in 38 degree water.
So when you're trying to get
support for something like
that and convince people that
this is possible and it can
happen, it's really difficult
to convince them.
So I wrote letters to people
every single day.
And I just kept trying.
As I was swimming and working
out, I was thinking about who
else can I contact?
Who else do I know who
might know somebody?
And I had friends who were
mountain climbers, who knew
Armand Hammer.
So I went to Armand Hammer,
who was the huge
Occidental Oil guy.
And his assistant wound up
writing to the Soviet consul
general to the US, based
in San Francisco.
So I went up to see him
and met with him.
And he really took this project
on and believed it
might be possible.
But what initially happened was
I wrote to Brezhnev and
never heard back.
He died.
And I wrote to Andropov
and he died.
And I wrote to Chernenko
And I wrote to Brezhnev
and I think that he
decided to answer me.
The other part was I had written
to Bob Walsh, who was
hired by Ted Turner to put
on the Goodwill Games.
And so through that channel,
I was able to
reach Gorbachev's assistant.
And through that communication
channel, that's how we got
Gorbachev's--
his attention.
In the meantime, the press
started picking up on that I
was going to go do the swim
and I didn't know if the
commission would come through.
So my goal was to go halfway,
to reach as far as I could.
And with the press getting
behind it, and then ABC
covered it, and then the "LA
Times" covered it, and the
media made this big deal of
it, we were able to take a
video and send it through our
contacts to the Kremlin.
But that was the other thing.
It's like what's the address
for the Kremlin?
How do I get a video
to Gorbachev?
I mean I don't know
any of this stuff.
And I contacted a former Russian
history professor from
college, who told me who
to talk to at the State
Department.
And then I found that there
was something called the
Russian desk.
So I contacted the Russian desk
person, who was really
engaged in this whole thing.
His name was Ed Salazar.
He was like this is
the best idea.
After 10 years of working
at it, somebody
going this is fantastic.
So he jumped on board.
And then because of him,
then the Assistant
Secretary of State.
And then US Ambassador to
Russia, the Russian Ambassador
to the US-- oh, Soviet
Ambassador to the US.
And I eventually started
building this team.
And then got Senator Frank
McCloskey from Alaska.
I mean it just continued.
It snowballed.
And basically the day before
the swim happened, we got a
call from Senator McCloskey's
office saying that the
clearance had come through for
the swim and we could do it.
And it was so exciting to have
worked for 11 years and have
this huge dream, and this huge
hope that the border could be
opened between the two
countries, and to have the
phone call saying yes,
it's possible.
But in my head, I had been
thinking all this time that
I'm only going to be
able to go halfway.
And suddenly I'm thinking,
oh my gosh, I got to
go all the way now.
And so it sort of like
shifted everything.
And the other part that was
really exciting was that we
had supporters from Little
Diomede Island who were Inuit,
who had had family on
Big Diomede Island.
But they had all been
moved by the
Soviets to mainland Siberia.
So they had lost contact with
their family for 48 years.
So we were allowed two
cruise boats to go
across the Bering Strait.
And they didn't have
to have visas.
It was agreed in advance by
telex, there weren't faxes
then, by telex that we'd have
these two umiak boats, which
were two walrus skin boats
that were 30 feet long.
And they would accompany me
along the swim, along with AP,
and "Los Angeles Times," and
ABC, and a bunch of media that
would be there to document the
swim and to document the
border opening.
And the hard thing that happened
was that suddenly all
of the people in the community
wanted to go across with us.
So they're pulling out
all these umiaks.
And many of them that hadn't
been used for a couple years
and their skins were
stretched out.
And the gut that they used to
sew the skins to the frame
weren't really tight.
So I'm thinking, oh my gosh,
we don't have enough life
jackets in the boat for them.
And what happens if something
goes wrong?
And there's a point where I
just go, you know, I can't
take care of all this.
I just have to do the
swim and hope that
everything will work out.
And I thought well, if something
goes wrong maybe the
Soviets will come in and
rescue our crew.
So it was a really wild and
crazy, but that was the swim.
And it really took forever,
but it opened the border.
And that was in August of '87.
In December, President Gorbachev
and President Reagan
were meeting at the White
House to sign
the IMF missile treaty.
And it was their first summit.
And President Gorbachev and
President Reagan stood up.
And President Gorbachev raised
his glass and said, it took a
daring American girl by the
name of Lynne Cox just two
hours to swim between
our two countries.
And it said it showed how close
to each other the two
countries are and how the
relations between the two
countries were improving.
And it made me feel like wow,
you can have a huge dream.
And you can go to a lot of
people who will help you and
you can make it happen.
And after that, the border
between the two
countries was opened.
And the people that have lived
on Little Diomede Island that
hadn't seen their families for
48 years, were able to go back
and forth freely.
And they created an
international park up further
in the Bering Strait that was
co-administered between the US
and the Soviet Union.
And then commercial stuff
opened up, where Alaska
Airlines started to fly from
Alaska directly to the
Siberian and the Far East.
And fishing stuff changed.
And there were big changes that
resulted in that tiny,
little effort.
But it was really fantastic.
It was
really so cool Any--
you had, yes?
AUDIENCE: It's on.
OK.
You said the longest swim,
how long was it?
It was seven hours?
LYNNE COX: The longest swim
I swam was when I
was 14 years old.
And I swam 12 hours
and 36 minutes
across Catalina Channel.
When I swam the English
Channel the first
time, I swam 30 miles.
The second time I
swam 33 miles.
AUDIENCE: So my question is what
do you do for nutrition
and hydration to keep fueled
throughout that whole time?
LYNNE COX: Actually,
I'm still learning
how to do that better.
Initially when I swam the
English Channel, water bottles
hadn't been invented yet.
So my mom came up with the
idea of using old shampoo
bottles and using that
for our feeding.
And we would try all sorts of
things like hot tea with honey
or hot orange juice, which
is absolutely disgusting.
We tried hot cocoa.
But that was not good with the
salt that you would get in
your mouth for hours.
You'd have like salt in.
So you had to figure out a fluid
that could warm you up,
that would taste good, and that
would give you energy.
And I finally came up
with warm apple
cider, warm apple juice.
Because it was something that
would coat my throat.
It with something that was a
simple sugar that moms give
their kids, babies, as
their first drink.
You know the first fruit
drink that they get
usually is apple juice.
It's easy to digest.
So I figured I would use
that for my swam.
So I periodically, on
the English Channel
I'd feed every hour.
And I'd have a small,
half glass, or--
yeah, have a cup of apple
juice or maybe a cup.
And then the other thing I would
have would be oatmeal
cookies, oatmeal
raisin cookies.
Because when you swim for long
periods of time, you get
really hungry.
And I've always wanted
solid food.
I haven't enjoyed drinking
whatever it is that you're
supposed to drink.
So it's really interesting
though because my roommate in
college was Sandy Nielsen.
And she was the gold medalist
in the '72 games in the
100-meter freestyle.
And we were talking about
our training.
what we ate one day.
And I said, Sandy, what did you
eat before you got your
gold medal in the
100 freestyle?
She said I had big bowl of
oatmeal with raisins.
I'm like amazing, that you find
the same things coming
from different sports.
The other thing that I've done
through the years is I've
really gone to other athletes
to learn from them.
And a good friend does
ultra-marathon runs.
She's Kathy Kusner.
She was a gold medalist in the
'76 games in horse jumping.
And she went on to become
a marathon runner and an
ultra-marathon runner.
And she's 73 now.
But she was doing 100-mile
runs until she was 70.
And now, she just
does marathons.
That's all she does now,
a real slacker.
But she also eats very simply.
And she eats oatmeal.
And she doesn't do the
high-tech, high-power,
high-fuel stuff.
Because a lot of that stuff
causes gastric dumping.
It causes gas and makes you
really comfortable.
And so she goes more with
water and fruit juice.
And her friend though, and I
haven't tried this out yet,
who does ultra-marathon runs,
she's probably in her 50s.
She is now trying to eat
avocados during the runs
because you want a high fat or
she wants a high-fat, energy
substance to eat.
And she says avocados are
really easy to eat.
And I'm thinking, wow, with all
the salt in your throat,
that would be like guacamole.
But I mean the other thing that
I learned from her and
her friends are that on their
long-distance marathon runs,
they cut up peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches and eat
pieces of them during
their runs.
And I thought wow,
that's so wild.
Because before my swim across
the Beagle Channel at the very
tip of South America, I decided
that I needed to try
something new.
And I wound up eating bagels
with peanut butter and jelly.
And that gave me energy
and sustained me.
It sort of just sat there
for the whole swim.
So I think though there's no
answer for anyone to say this
is what you need to drink and
this is how you need to feed.
I think it's really about trying
out what will work for
you and what you're
happy with.
Just like you might like a
certain food or you might be
allergic to a certain food, what
works for you might not
work for somebody else.
I think now that open water
swimmers who are doing five
and 10 miles swims are feeding
more frequently.
They're feeding every
20 minutes or so.
And they're short feedings.
Because every time you stop to
feed, you start to get cold.
And I learned that when you do
that, you sort of never get
back to where you were
before you stopped.
You always feel that cold moving
a little bit deeper
into your body.
So I don't really like
to stop and feed.
And when I do those really cool
swims, I don't stop for
anything because your
body temperature
gets lowered so quickly.
And that's the other
thing that happens.
On these swims, and you might
experience it if you're doing
some of these open water swims
or during triathlons during
the swimming phase, your
temperature can drop because
you've been swimming in cooler
water and your skin's exposed
to the colder water.
And then you get out
and you vasodilate.
You start to open the blood flow
from the peripheral area
and it goes into your core.
And then you notice
that you're cold.
That's called "afterdrop."
What I've learned from the swim
in Greenland was that in
the past I had sort of stopped,
and put warm clothes
on, and drank warm fluids.
Not hot foods because your lips
are cooled down to the
water temperature.
So the last thing you want to
start drinking is hot fluids
because you'll just scorch
your lips and mouth.
So you wanted to start
off with warm fluids.
But what I learned after the
swim in Greenland, or what I
thought about, was instead of
just stopping in shivering,
and then warming my body up that
way, and then drinking
warm fluids, what I'll do
instead is I'll walk through
the town of Illulissat, which
is very, very, very hilly.
I'll make sure I have
my sweatsuit on.
And I'll go back to the
hotel that way.
So after half an hour walk, my
core temperature had warmed up
significantly.
And I'd get into a shower
that was just cool.
And then within 20 minutes,
I warmed it up to
warmer, then hot.
And it was back to normal.
Whereas in Antarctica, I
shivered for an hour straight
and felt really uncomfortable
and exhausted by shivering for
an hour straight.
And then after that took
a warm shower.
One of the things that I wrote
about in this book that's so
important, that I learned from
the Gordon Giesbrecht, the
world's expert on hypothermia,
is that if somebody is ever
hypothermic, never put
them in a hot shower.
Because if you put them in a hot
shower, it causes them to
vasodilate, dilate open the
blood flow along the surface
of the body, and it will throw
the cold blood into the core.
And it can cause their whole
system to collapse
and they can die.
So there are people that do
these cold swims that say we
go right into the sauna
afterwards.
And I also hear about those
who go into the sauna
afterwards often pass out.
And it's because of that shift
in blood moving in and out.
So just one of those things
that's really important, that
I sort of noted in a big
way in the book.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So for people who are
just getting started with
open water swimming, what are
the key dangers, watch-outs,
and key skills that you need in
order to be safe doing it?
LYNNE COX: Well, that's the
big part of the book.
Maybe I'll just give it
from my experience.
Before I do any swim
anywhere, I spend--
it depends on the swim--
but if I was to go swimming off
Brighton Beach right now,
I would be asking--
first, I'd try to find out if
there's someplace around here
where they measure water quality
and find out is the
water clean?
Because I'm swimming because
I want to be healthy.
I don't want to go swimming
and get sick.
That's the last thing
I want to do.
So I'd find out about the water
quality in the area.
Then I would contact the captain
of the lifeguards and
find are there problems with
sting rays, jellyfish, sharks?
Are there certain times of the
year where it's better to swim
and where there aren't
better times to swim?
What's the prevailing current?
Is there a big temperature
change from cold to hot?
And then I would continue
through friends who are
swimmers to gather
information.
And then I compare
that information.
Because one person might tell
you one thing and somebody
might tell you something else.
And one might be right and
the other might not be.
So I usually sort of
triangulated every answer that
I got to see if I could get that
same answer repetitively.
And then I would use that
as OK, that's what
I'm going to do now.
Actually, I think that it's
a really methodical and
progressive way of doing
the research.
Now, I have Google.
And you won't believe
how much I use it to
be able to ask questions.
And Google Scholar,
it's like oh, my
gosh, this is so fantastic.
And then to access people and to
be able to track them down
and ask individuals who
know stuff about the
environment or the water.
And I do all that first.
And then I will go to the beach
and I'll talk to the
lifeguard or a number of
lifeguards on the beach.
And ask them about the current,
how fast it flows,
which way it goes, are
their rip tides?
Are there things that I
need to be concerned
about in the water?
I remember training for Cook
Strait in an area called
Island Bay, New Zealand.
And it was this beautiful
bay that
was really well protected.
It was just like lapis
blue water, so clear.
And I get in there and
started swimming.
And I was doing a really
good work out.
And I decided I need
to pick up my pace.
And I hadn't even thought, I
mean this was when I was 17
years old, so I hadn't even
thought of asking is there
anything I should know
about this waterway
before I get in it?
And I had worked with the
local lifeguards.
But I still didn't ask
that question.
So I was swimming along and I
ran head first into a piling.
And I came out afterwards and
said did you guys know there
was a piling over there?
It's like, oh yeah, that used
to be part of the old pier.
I'm like, ah.
So honestly, you don't want
to get injured while
you're doing your swim.
So that was the other thing is
are there other questions that
I haven't asked you, but that
I should know about?
Because I really am not from
this area and I'm just trying
to learn before I get in.
And so that sort of endears you
to the local people too.
And they can't help
you enough.
And that's what's so cool
about this open water,
triathlon, athlete community.
People will really
help you out.
But that's really what makes it
fun too, to be able to swim
with somebody and share that
experience afterwards.
I think though I spent a lot
of time, maybe an hour.
And then the other thing that
I do, because of doing the
research for this book, I met a
man named Shawn Collins, who
started Surfline.com.
And it's the premier place for
surfers to go online to find
out what's going on with the
surf around the world.
And he was so cool because he
could look at weather systems
around the world and figure out
where a storm was being
generated off Fiji, and the
speed of the storm, and the
height of the waves that would
occur from that storm.
And he could do that looking at
all the charts and find--
I mean the weather information
and weather maps.
And he could also do that
with the Pacific
Northwest or whatever.
And I was at his home one day
in Seal Beach, California.
And we were sitting there,
looking out at the water.
And he was watching the
waves coming in
and breaking on shore.
And he says oh, that's from
the storm off Hawaii.
That's from the storm off
Washington state.
That's from the storm
off Fiji.
And he could tell by looking
at the waves.
He said each one has
a fingerprint.
And I'm like wow.
I spent my life in the ocean
and I didn't know that.
And he gave me this new,
beautiful way and awareness of
looking at the waves.
But I would also check
Surfline.com to find out about
what the wave situations
are before I go.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if you
ever had any close encounters
with marine life--
LYNNE COX: Oh, I've had--
AUDIENCE: --or interesting
stories?
LYNNE COX: I've had
lots of close
encounters with marine life.
Sometimes its been really
wonderful and exciting.
And sometimes it's been
really not so great.
The wonderful one was my second
book, where I had a
baby gray whale, who was
swimming underneath me in the
early morning.
I was training.
I would never train
this way now.
But when I was 17 years old, I
was training just outside the
wave break before the
Sun has risen.
And I felt something very big
swimming underneath me.
And I kept swimming the
half mile to the
jetty and turned around.
And I started swimming
back faster.
And I kept thinking,
is it's a seal?
It's like no, it's
big for a seal.
Is it a dolphin?
No, it's not a dolphin.
And I couldn't see what
was below me.
So I just swam faster.
And then got to the pier and
decided to get out of the
water and saw an old
fishermen, named
Steve, who I knew.
And he was waving to
me to come out to
the end of the pair.
So I did.
And he explained that I had a
baby great whale, who had lost
his mom, who had been
following me.
And that I needed to stay
in the water and help
him find his mom.
So if was like how
do you do that?
But I just thought
OK, I'll do that.
And so for the next five
hours, we swam
all over that area.
And eventually mom showed up.
So that was like one of
the most wonderful
experiences in swimming.
There was a swim that I did,
that I wrote in the book
"Swimming to Antarctica.
And I was trying to become the
first person to swim around
the Cape of Good Hope from
the Indian Ocean--
I mean, sorry-- from the
Atlantic Ocean around into the
Indian Ocean.
And where those two oceans meet,
there is huge current
and lots of upwelling.
And it's very difficult
to swim there.
But because of the upwelling
and the current,
there's a lot to fish.
And because there's
lots of fish,
there's lots of sea lions.
And because there's
lots of sea lions,
there's mega sharks.
And so in preparation for that
swim, there were four guys who
were from the Special Forces
team, South African Special
Forces team, who agreed to be in
the water spotting for me.
So they were taking turns.
Every 20 minutes, one guy would
jump in and hold onto a
rope and have a spear gun in
his hand, with a mask and
snorkel on, and watch
for sharks.
And then after 20 minutes, the
other guy would jump in.
Well, I was about 400 meters
from finishing the swim and
Doug, the diver who was next to
me, suddenly disappeared.
And I had a Zodiac boat
off to my right
for additional support.
So I was yelling at the crew.
They were saying,
where's Doug?
And they were looking and they
couldn't see anything because
the water was so rough.
So I yelled to the people in the
other boat where Doug was
supposed to be attached
to, the 40-foot boat.
And they couldn't
see him either.
So the crew started yelling
at me just to swim faster.
And two South Africa swimmers,
who were on board the boat,
jumped in the water to swim with
me, to make me go faster.
And I'm thinking, I don't need
anyone to make me go faster.
I know that there's something
going on here.
And wow, you're swimming
with me.
So we sprinted to shore.
And then when we landed on
shore, Doug came ashore in the
Zodiac boat.
And he was stretching out the
spear from a spear gun, which
is about that long and it was
about half a inch in diameter.
And he said that he shot a
bronze Whaler shark, which is
a migratory shark that
only comes there in
December and January.
He shot the shark in
the dorsal fin.
And the shark just turned and
bit the spear, and bent it in
half, and pulled it out of
its fin, and swam away.
So he said that he was concerned
that the blood in
the water would attract
more sharks.
And I said I was too.
And that there was no problem
because we sprinted to shore.
But we had prepared for it.
The other option for that swim
would have been to swim in a
shark cage.
The problem with swimming
in a shark cage is
that you get 30% drag.
So you're not making it
under your own power.
But the other thing about the
Cape of Good Hope is because
it's at the tip of Africa, it
encounters lots of storms by
just sitting there
the way it is.
And so there are waves that come
up from Antarctica, that
in the winter, are between 80
and 90 feet, that break on
shore there.
In summer time, they're
a lot smaller.
They're between 20
and 30 feet.
There are rogue waves
that just suddenly
appear out of nowhere.
So we figured out though that
if I was swimming in a cage,
the wave could take the cage
down with me in it
and the boat too.
So we figured that in setting up
that swim, the idea to have
the Special Forces guys with
me was much better than to
swim in a cage.
And I didn't want to swim in the
cage because I felt like
that was cheating.
AUDIENCE: You shared a lot about
the external elements,
like physical endurance.
I'm very curious about
the inner element.
And has this transformed you
as a person, and have you
looked at other aspects
outside of swimming
differently because of your
journey, and if you could
share a few anecdotes on that?
LYNNE COX: I hope I can remember
all your questions.
There is a real inner journey
when you're doing these swims
because you're in your
own little world.
It's your think tank.
And so you do spend a lot of
time talking to yourself and
convincing yourself.
Like the Cook Strait swim, when
you've gone backwards for
five hours and you expected to
have finished after five
hours, it's a big letdown,
a huge letdown.
So I learned through that swim
that you just keep going until
you get there.
And I think that I learned that
to apply that to life.
With my first book, "Swimming
to Antarctica," it took 21
years to get it published.
But it became a best seller
on the "New York Times"
bestseller list.
And then "Grayson" took a year
to write and then I think a
year to get published.
And that was another
best seller.
So I realize that there's this
transference that you can make
from what you do in your time
that you just are spending and
enjoying life to what you
take in to the bigger
part of your life.
I think that for me--
actually I was invited
to speak in India.
And I brought to Mumbai to speak
to 700 eminent people.
And one family had brought
two of their sons.
And there was one boy
there who was maybe
9 or 10 years old.
And he said to me, what you
do must be 90% mental.
That so much of it must be just
in your mind, of your
ability or nonability
to do it.
And I thought about
that for a minute.
And I said actually you
know I could think
that I could do it.
And that's a great way
to help prepare.
But if I don't physically train
to do it, then mentally
I'm not prepared to do it and
physically and mentally I
can't do it.
So it involves all of that.
And I think the other part too
is there is a spiritual part
of it where that whole sense
of extending yourself, of
seeing what you can do, of
trying to create more
challenges and then realize
them and be able to grow
through that challenge, that's
part of what drives me to do
these things.
I think that life would be
really boring and not as
fulfilling as--
I mean just right now, going
across the country and doing
the book tour, the people that
I meet, the questions that
they have, the exchanges
we have, are
really rich and enriching.
And I feel so fortunate to have
written books and to be
able to communicate ideas.
And then to have people come
back with better ideas than
what I've had or embellish
them and come up with
something more.
And I think that's one
of the most rewarding
parts of this journey.
Did I get all the questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LYNNE COX: OK.
Thank you.
Any more?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I've been lucky
enough to jump into the Hudson
River two years in a
row as part of the
New York City triathlon.
The first year, I didn't know
what to expect so I sort of
had that moment of panic and
said OK, pull it together.
This year I'm like well, you
know what's ahead of you.
But do you have any tips or
advice for like that moment of
jumping in and keeping
yourself together and
completing what your goal is?
LYNNE COX: I totally
understand that.
I was just talking to a friend
of mine who played on the
national team and who was an
amazing water polo player.
And he said he did his first
triathlon with 1,200 people,
maybe five years ago.
And he said he had that moment
where 1,200 people were being
released all at once.
And he said, I was so anxious.
And he played water
polo and that's a
really physical sport.
So we discussed that.
And I think that for me the
way to not be as anxious--
because like when I was going
to jump into 32 degree water
off Antarctica there was a
moment I'm walking down the
steps and they feel like
ice cube trays.
And then I'm sitting on
it, waiting to sort of
slide into the water.
And I'm thinking, wow, this is
going to be really difficult,
and it's going to be cold,
and am I going to be OK?
So I go back to I
train for it.
I'm prepared for it.
I've done what I needed to do
and now this is the moment I
get to do it.
And that's really a great way
to start off, like finally I
get to do it.
Instead of like, oh, my gosh,
what's going to go wrong?
It's like what's going
to go right?
And all the stuff I've learned
through all this time, how can
I now apply it for
this moment?
Because no matter how hard you
train, there will be stuff
that comes up and it will
be something new.
It was so cool, the last of
couple years I got a chance to
work with the SEALs,
Navy SEALs.
And what I learned from them
was that they prepare, and
prepare, and train, and train,
and train, and train.
And they do things so that it
becomes part of muscle memory.
And so that when something weird
happens, they've already
covered all those other bases
and then they can deal with
whatever is new.
And I thought that was so
helpful to be able to have
that mindset of you've done
everything you can.
But now, you're the athlete and
you can find the balance
you need to do what you need to
do and shift the thinking
from oh, my god, now what,
to oh, I get to go now.
I hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: Did you
ever flatline?
LYNNE COX: Did I ever flatline,
what a great question?
Yeah, actually I-- ugh.
OK.
I once was invited to swim
in a race in Nile River.
And we were supposed
to swim around two
islands in the Nile.
And one of my mentors was a man
named Fami Attala, who had
attempted the English Channel
five times and never made it.
But he had done an 80-mile swim
in the Mediterranean.
He grew up in Egypt.
And he told me that you'll
have like the best swim.
It'll be the best thing.
It'll be the best experience.
Because in Egypt, open water
swimming there is such a big
thing that they name streets
after their heroes.
Abouheif was one of their
swimmers that
swam the English Channel.
So he has a street named
after him in Cairo.
And it's part of their
mythology.
It's bigger than being
an NFL quarterback is
in the United States.
So Fami got me all excited and
set up to do the swim.
And I got dysentery the week
before I swam, but decided I
was the only American there
representing the United States.
So I had to do my best.
So I jumped into the water and
swam 15 of the 20 miles and
pretty much passed
out in the water.
And wound up in the ER room
in Egypt, in Cairo, Egypt.
Which was really kind of
fortunate because the doctor
who was attending to me had
studied in Britain and spoke
English fluently.
And I was so upset because
I had failed.
I mean I had really failed.
And he couldn't understand
why I was so upset.
And I kept saying well, but I
didn't complete the swim.
And he saying, but
you don't get it.
You could have died.
You were severely dehydrated.
Your muscles were cramping.
And you could have died.
Like, yeah, but I didn't
finish the swim.
I mean I was 17 years old.
I'm like aah.
And so it took me years
to figure out oh, I
pushed it too far.
I was really dehydrated.
I really could have died.
And no swim is ever
worth that.
So it put everything from
then on in perspective.
But for a while, that
failure haunted me.
Because with the Cook Strait
swim that came after that, I
almost quit on that swim after
swimming for five hours and
not getting anywhere.
But then the support
crew continued to
say you can do it.
You can keep going.
And so I just thought OK,
I can keep going.
So 12 hours later, I made it.
But that swim in the Nile
was really awful.
Because it was also extremely
polluted.
And I was swimming through areas
of dead rats that were
floating around and dead dogs.
And it was really bad.
Yeah.
I wouldn't recommend it.
Don't swim in the Nile?
A happier question?
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
Whenever I hit a certain
mileage,
my foot always cramps.
So what do you do?
What do you do when
you have cramps?
LYNNE COX: Actually,
I just grab my foot
and stretch it out.
And that helps to
ease the cramp.
AUDIENCE: So are you always
just treading water?
You have your support crew.
Do you hold onto your--
LYNNE COX: You never
hold onto the boat.
But I don't know if this is in
training or if this is during
an actual race.
If it's during training, I would
just hold on to whatever
and do that.
But usually what happens with
cramps is that somebody has
either their electrolytes are
out of balance and so maybe
you're aren't having enough
calcium, or sodium chloride,
or anything.
Maybe you need to talk to your
doctor or whatever and find
out if you should have
something more, more
electrolyte replacement.
The other thing that happens
though is your muscles fatigue
at a certain point.
And so maybe you're not training
hard enough, those
muscles in your feet, to prepare
you for the swim.
Maybe they're fatiguing and
that's causing the cramping.
Or the other thing is you
may be kicking too hard.
A lot of swimmers don't realize
that 80% of their
propulsion comes from
their arms.
And their legs are
more for balance.
And so if you're kicking really
hard, you're using all
the energy that could
be pulling you
forward with your arms.
So if you look at me swim, and I
did the long distance stuff,
you'll see my stoke
is really arms.
And my legs are just balance.
So you might try backing off
on you kick a little bit.
So then you can use your oxygen
for your arms and pull
more strongly with your
arms and see if that
increases your speed.
And then you don't get the
cramps in your feet.
You know, like a variety of
things you might try.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
LYNNE COX: Oh, sure.
AUDIENCE: So swimming for such
a long distance, how do you
keep straight?
LYNNE COX: When I'm swimming for
such a long distance, how
do I keep straight?
I always have boats with me that
are supporting me during
the actual swim.
So on board the boat will
be usually a doctor.
And there will be lifeguards
and sometimes a paramedic.
But on the big, really cold
swims, I've actually had three
doctors there just in case
something goes wrong.
Because again, I'm going to
places nobody's been and I've
never been.
So I want to make sure
there's back up.
And they also go through this
rehearsal ahead of the swim to
make sure they can
take care of me.
When I'm training offshore,
I swim just
outside the wave break.
And I swim usually in an area,
either it's roped off, so I
know I can follow the
rope along the way.
Or I swim outside
the wave break.
And there's a pier in Seal Beach
where put-- there's a
tower and I put it on my back.
And then in the distance, there
are three Oil Islands,
White, Chaffee, and Grissom,
that were named after the
Apollo 11 astronauts that were
killed in the Apollo mission.
And they have lights on them.
So if it's late afternoon or
early evening, I can use those
lights as my guide.
So I'll swim along
and I'll look up.
But the other thing that I do
that really helps you swim in
the open water is to be able
to breathe on both sides.
Because if you can breathe on
both sides, then you can see
on both sides.
And you can swim in a
more balanced way.
But you also can see what's
around you for safety.
And so there might be a jet
skier coming off this side.
And if you don't breathe
on that side, you
might not see him.
Or a wind surfer on this side--
and if you only breath
on this side, then you won't
see the wind surfer and you
might not hear him.
So it's just really important
to be able to see, and look,
and use your eyes.
That will help your
body balance.
AUDIENCE: And a quick
question.
Did you wear the thermal suit
or the normal bathing suit?
LYNNE COX: Normal
bathing suit.
Usually it's a TYR
It's just a Lycra swimsuit,
like the Lycra shorts that
cyclists wear.
So I'll wear the Lycra swimsuit
because it doesn't
chafe as much.
If you wear a nylon or a
polyester swim suit, that, if
you're swimming a long way, even
if it's a short way, it
can start chaffing.
So I wrote all about that.
So it's all in there about
how to prepare.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LYNNE COX: Thank
you very much.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
all we have time for.
Thank you for joining
us today.
LYNNE COX: Thank
you very much.
It was great.
Thank you.